nous sommes à tourner chez à quelques
pas de la frontière franco-belge e
frontières traversé chaque jour par de
nombreux français et ils sont encore
plus nombreux depuis ces derniers jours
et l'instauration en france du pass
sanitaire dans la majorité des lieux de
vie publique dans l'hexagone et pour
cause chez nos voisins belges eux pas
besoin de ce document pour aller au ciné
se faire un resto ou encore boire un
verre se passe sanitaire français fait
le bonheur des restaurateurs de la grand
place de tournai c'est le cas de jean 50
ans patron d'un nouvel établissement il
a vu la fréquentation de sa clientèle
française bondir de 30% cette semaine
depuis ce problème de passer un été en
france on va vraiment une forte montée
de la clientèle française qui arrivent
ici à tournai déjà avant il y en avait
et là encore beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
plus à des français qu'ils n'hésitent
pas à traverser la frontière à pied à
vélo ou en voiture
l'objectif est clair continuer à vivre
normalement
là où c'est possible
on est venu manger tranquillement sans
passé ni temps pour éviter ces mesures
d' absurde totalement liberticide la
france devient
un pays totalitaire on est plus libre
maintenant on nous impose aux menaces le
peuple français et voilà on a la
possibilité de venir ici à quelques
kilomètres pouvoir confites et donc on
profite et du soleil et de la joie et de
la liberté n'est pas du tout le poste à
l'inter je ne compte pas du tout me
faire vacciner et on est venu à ce
restaurant pour faire ce qu'on peut plus
faire en france maintenant et va
profiter justement du beau temps et
boire un verre le président macron a dit
que le pass à lithaire de ne serait
jamais obligatoire
visiblement il le devient par a beaucoup
de moyens et je pas du tout pour pour
bénéficier d'un pass sanitaires il faut
être vaccinés détenir un test de
dépistage négatif ou avoir récemment
guéri du kobe 19 en belgique le pass
sanitaire est loin d'être généralisée
il n'est pour l'heure obligatoire que
pour les évènements de plus de 1500
personnes et si certains refusent de
voir s'appliquer dans leur pays un
dispositif similaire à celui instauré en
france d'autres y sont favorables pour
la santé de tous distille pour moi la
santé pour l'ensemble de la population
est plus importante que simplement le
fait de se faire vacciner pour une
personne est donc pour moi il n'y a pas
de
il n'ya pas l'amalgamme je dire c'est le
var le vaccin est une bonne chose d anti
vacances pour moi je comprends pas très
bien l'europe et leur réaction et pour
moi ce sont des gens qui sont sous
informés donc moi je suis vacciné j'ai
fait les deux vaccins mais on me l'a pas
imposée à partir du moment donné on
m'aurait dit maintenant tu es obligé
sinon tu ne peux pas avoir accès à 6 à
l'afr ceci cela on m'enlève mais liberté
on m'agresse en fait c'est une agression
cette histoire là et donc c'est normal
que ça divise le peuple en france je
peux comprendre très bien cette division
c'est certainement une limitation des
libertés
s'est créé deux catégories de citoyens
ceux qui sont en règle au point de vue
sanitaire
et ce et les autres
c'est aussi une hypocrisie de la part de
l'état parce qu'on dit vous êtes libre
de vous faire vacciner ou pas mais si
vous ne vous faites pas vacciner alors
vous pouvez pas faire ceci cela cette
situation liée au pass sanitaire fait
grincer des dents de nombreux
commerçants et restaurateurs français il
dénonce en effet une concurrence
déloyale et demande une harmonisation
des règles à la frontière